I can practically feel my heels lifting
already yes this is what I was supposed
to do bring you back here it feels right
it does this scene is sort of this
moment where everything has kind of been
upended Barbie's bringing Gloria and
Sasha back to Barbie land to try to be
like look at how wonderful things can be
oh that's strange
wow cuz that's
the I have baby treat me
incoming bruski
beer so that's our president with the
beer and the cheering Squad is the
Supreme Court this is so much better
than being president something's weird
today no one's meant to feel
self-conscious in Bobby land until Bobby
starts having an existential crisis but
before that it would never occur to her
that being in a bikini could be
embarrassing it's like she feels great
they will feel great every day is great
anyway uh wait until you see my dream
house everything I've bought and owned
will totally inspire you and we can
change clothes again she comes and it's
this feeling of like this something is a
miss here what happened here everything
basically everything exists to expand
and Elevate the presence of men that's
amazing beautiful I know Barbie
here what have you
done what are you
wearing don't question it just roll with
with a tiny baby tiny baby don't call me
baby what about mini baby like this mini
fridge no Ken this is my dream housee it
is my dream housee it's mine Barbie and
Ken had come to our world and while
they're there they discover different
things Barbie thinks that Barbie saved
women and Ken is surprised to encounter
a world in which he is acknowledged as
having any kind of importance at all
Miken was created as a accessory he only
exists within the warmth of her gaze he
has no identity of his own he's in a
kind of existential hell this is no
longer Barbie's Dream housee this shall
henceforth be known as Ken's Mojo Dojo
Casa house try it Mojo Doo Mojo Dojo
Casa
house boy and one thing that we did
design-wise was they didn't really
change anything they just put on top of
whatever was there and it almost has
that like plastered over it quality and
they just like plopped a black leather
couch down in the lawn and they and they
put a basketball hoop and a pull up bar
they've just pasted it on everything you
you know that you're doing for Barbie
you're going to see the transition into
kendam and uh there's a lot of fun in in
that you know in what happens with
kendam and what comes in from The Real
World you find that there is a beauty
that comes from a massing sometimes and
aesthetic objects together the immediate
thing is from the absence of things to
create the beauty is the chaos of things
that he's brought back and the color
palette changes you know we're now
bringing in the blacks the whites you
know he can have electricity he can all
these things that were forbidden he's
also got a giant Hummer car there's a
rationale to everything that is put in
there there's the lazy boys the mini
fridges and then of course horses
everywhere you know we made so many
lampshades towels everything everywhere
but behind all that is all still Barbie
Dreamhouse because he hasn't cleared
anything out he's just pushed it to the
side and it's an interesting thing
because it's kind of you know it's not
that it gets it's still it's still has
to be toy so it doesn't get dirty or you
know kind of you know the it's a very
things are put on it it's not it's not
bedded in everything's on it it's very
kind of surface isn't it it's the kind
of that transformation know it's just
like all these tiny flourishes that I
think just make everything you look at
it's like even more detailed than you
can imagine that goes for the
performances and the costumes and the
sets it's just maximalist in the designs
and the architecture in the in the props
themselves there's layers of things
happening where it's it's fun to look at
there was an embracing of what is
artificial to achieve an effect an
emotion I felt that my role in This was
um as much as possible supporting that
notion of
these are indeed Barbies and kin and so
they're dolls but for them Barbie land
is is a real world you know and this is
where they've been and and it's supposed
to feel authentic to them so I I strive
to do as much as possible delighting uh
the the the feeling of it it is it is a
real place place even though it looks so
fake but for them it's real I'm just
having some brusi beers in my Mojo Dojo
Casa
house you can stay if you want as my
bride wife or my long-term low
commitment distance girlfriend what do
you
say brusy beer me I will not bruski beer
you Barbie and Ken they're dolls so we
were always thinking about children
playing with them that there was this
childlike aspect to both of them there's
a naive quality but also a playfulness
and even a kind of wickedness that
children have and certainly in the Ken
world he understands them kind of like a
kid does in that way of like I see that
and that and that and the horse and The
Mink and the and I'm just going to put
them all on Ryan he and Greta had
discussed the sliced alone fur coat and
Ryan had said yes definitely I want to
wear that so that became for me a guide
to how far we could go and I and I have
to say that however far I pushed it Ryan
would always come up with something else
it's exaggerated because it's Ken you
know and Ken just goes the full look
there's no Nuance or anything it's just
complete and in in a way that's right
because that is what Barbies and Ken do
jacine always said Barbie doesn't dress
for the day she dresses for the activity
I thought that was a good way to
understand her it was kind of fun to
jump into a slightly different version
it's like every time Barbie changes her
outfit she's morphing into something
else a different vibe there's a meme out
right now that says the caution designer
for Barbie has a free pass to
[Music]
heaven and I I agree buckle up baby
because Barbie land it's now kenland and
it's going to be just like Century City
in Los Angeles because they had it all
figured out in Century City the minute
you get out of your car you're like I
can't believe how great this place is no
no no they don't have it figured out in
Century City because we failed them no
you failed
me so much of Ken's journey is that like
Ken is truly the this forgotten man like
when she says you can go
now I thought I might stay over tonight
why cuz we're girlfriend boyfriend to do
what I'm actually not sure and you know
everybody laughs and it's funny and he
just accepts it that actually that hurt
him and that when you hear it the other
way you're like ooh that's hurtful and
it was hurtful the first time if you'll
excuse
me this is my Mojo Dojo a house it's not
Barbie's Mojo Dojo Kasa
house
right how's that
feel it is not fun is it Ryan and I
talked a lot about that he's doing this
because on some level he thinks maybe
then she'll respect him that she'll like
him because he sees that men in the real
world seem to have women who like them
as more than just like something that
goes with her outfit so he thinks oh
well maybe this will be a a way that I
can win her even though it's obviously
wrong-headed and then when she seems to
reject it he lashes
out barie take your lady Fashions with
you take your celebrate disco bell
bottoms and your icecapades pretty
practice suit and dazzling show skir
these are archival pajama jam in
Amsterdam set no and you're pretty
Paisley pazo pets go the pazo then get
out when Margot has her meltdown after
Ken has his meltdown we love that
because they're so dramatic so when
they're allowed to be dramatic they
they're like you know it's like like all
very Broad in that way and so you know
then culminating in her like you know
falling down on the ground and falling
over and then what Margot does so
wonderfully is sort of where you feel
the doll and where you feel the human
like when she falls down she's like a
doll again she's just sort of like in
nerd on the ground Margo is so precise
in how she approaches her characters
you're able to go on a real journey with
her because she's always able to make
things grounded and relatable and very
emotional even when it's ridiculous and
heightened and funny you never feel like
you lose the humanity and so I knew I
could take her on this madc cap
adventure and that you would never feel
left behind by her performance this is
the lowest I've ever been and that's the
moment that she actually starts her
transition into the real world
permanently so I think it was quite
important that we took her on that
journey of becoming human with visual
kind of tools as well like her hair
becoming more human the ideas were just
to really show this Evolution so it was
all those like subtle signals we're
trying to give the Audience by the end
of the film of like she's not a Barbie
anymore Barbie land is perfect but it's
it it's perfect in the eyes of a child
in a certain way so I think I saw it in
in a lot of ways of growing up and and
growing up is accepting mess and
accepting complication that's why I was
created I only
exist within the warmth of your
gaze without
it I'm just another Blood guy who can't
do flips one thing I loved about playing
this character is that just the extremes
to which he experiences everything the
highest highs and the lowest lows Ken
you have to figure out who you are
without
me why you're not your girlfriend you're
not your your house you're not your mink
Beach nope you're not even
Beach maybe it's Barbie
and it's
[Music]
Ken I want to give people a sense of
like you're okay and you have value just
as you are it is not something you earn
or you need to achieve you want to
celebrate everything women have done but
we also don't want to be saying like
unless you do that you haven't done
[Music]
enough I think that in a way symbols
like Barbie are important to be able to
reflect back the enoughness of just
being a girl being a woman being a
person and I think that's what I wanted
to explore in this
[Music]
movie